I trained six times a day and gained an
insane amount of weight and strength I
had a roommate named Greg Knuckles who's
really knowledgeable in the strength
space he suggested I try something
different lifting six times a day but
each time only taking 10 minutes to do
it so I set a timer and every 45 minutes
I do one set of three different
exercises and then I go back to work I
also adopted a pure carbohydrate diet
with no fat with the idea of being that
the efficiency of fat conversion to
stored fat is almost 100 while the
efficiency of carbohydrate storage and
if that is lower than that and so if I
had 200 grams of protein and 800 grams
of carbs with zero fat it was horrible
and unsustainable but I gained a lot of
weight and strength then I dialed back
the volume but I kept the split